juin est donc maintenant aux semaines on
va recevoir quelqu'un que vous
connaissez bien parce qu'il n'a pas été
pour rien dans dans votre carrière
c'est philippe pouvoir les voir bonsoir
alors bonjour et linda hardy has heureux
les demis france ici à toute façon on
tape bain et on a dit bon on a pas la
mer de fontenay on verrait si la vieille
à la maison avec son chapeau pour qu'ils
mettent les pieds dans l'eau tard
pourquoi vous êtes fâchés amical chapeau
non pas du tout on s'adore bon smiled
connaissait la route façon vous
connaissez tous le monde
alors philippe bouvard vous avez
longtemps sévi vous sévissez encore dans
la presse la radio la télé d'édition et
vous dites j'ai trouvé mon équilibre
dont le surmenage et quand vous êtes en
vacances en fait le travail et huit
heures par jour seulement 1 c'est ça oui
répond c'est les industriels je suis un
petit industriel man la limite de
l'artisanat le savent bien quand on
étend les fourneaux on n'est jamais sûr
blé rallumer oui c'est vrai alors ces
derniers temps c'est comme un petit peu
moins occupés 1
c'est à dire que vous avez plus france
soir si j'ai recommencé ce matin à jeudi
faut pas faire de la télé et dans les
journaux tous les matins j'ai vu ça
c'est en dernière page je crois c'est ça
oui
alors qu'elle enquêtait en première page
oui mais bon c'est déjà bien donc vous
êtes france soir donc de nouveau paris
match vous l'avez plus quand même non
non non vie continue à paraître
oui le figaro magazine perd 50 cellules
figaro va continuer oui alors sur france
3 à un taux moins de boulot parce que
boulevard du rire ça s'est arrêté pour
l'instant oui je suis arrêté c'est un
nouveau directeur de france 3 voilà
voilà un nouveau directeur nouveau
président alors on va voir si les têtes
qu'on voit sur le petit écran sont
nouvelles
si ce sont toujours les mêmes alors
reste les grosses têtes donc féval trois
ans sur sur rtl c'est il ya plus d'actu
il ya moins de sexe est un peu moins de
2 le sexe souvent d'actualité
ah bon vous me rassurez alors tu es face
a duré sept ans et l'émission était
arrêté pour vulgarité oui oui oui non
pas vulgarité non non mais à l'époque
pour reprendre la belle formule d'un de
ses dirigeants la chaîne était en quête
de sens oui nous on était plutôt en
quête de sens ouais et la puissante
aperçu mais sur le tard que on disait
des choses pas toujours très convenable
des heures 13 ouvrables et donc nous
sommes partis mais faut dire qu'on avait
tout dit à la télé oui et d'ailleurs
vous le savez tous les deux il n'est
jamais très facile d'adapter quelque
chose qui a marché à la radio au petit
écran elle seule peut vous le dire
alors j'ai fait un bouquin l'année
dernière s'applique pas lors du reiki
est un roman à clés sur tf1 qui a été
quand même censuré on n'a pas beaucoup
parlé en général on parle beaucoup plus
de vos livres ils n'étaient pas beaucoup
plus mauvais que les zones on en a parlé
deux musiciens ont été censurés dans
paris match par exemple un pack qui
essaimera est attaqué alors ben et
mathias et pas celle que je note c'est
que vous lui avez dit l'était pas pris
mauvais que les autres aux couples non
mais on en a parlé d'un truc de la merde
entre les deux que dans une émission de
télé et puis j'aime beaucoup la route
oui bon donc j'ai pas été complètement
censuré mais c'est vrai que j'allais un
peu contre l'établissment audiovisuel
que
puis une pâleur dur c'était le surnom
donné un des dirigeants de l'audiovisuel
mois bien sûr j'ai voulu faire le
portrait de personnes jeu que madame
deviers joncour qui a pris un ministre
comme ça tout à fait par hasard hasard
par hasard hein y'a même pas d'ailleurs
un ministre des affaires étrangères
il ya deux ministres étrangers aux
affaires un ministre de la halle de la
défense ce qui est normal pour un ancien
avocat
c'est donc et donc il ya des gens qui
sont imaginé que je voulais régler des
comptes
oui alors que généralement quand un
salarié et qui est une entreprise les
comptes se font dans l'autre sens mais
l'été moi j'ai été témoin en tous les
cas de la censure dont ce livre a été
été vite il voilà vous publier un
nouveau livre qui s'appelle joueurs mes
frères c'est chez robert laffont voilà
donc c'est le 38e en 38 ans 1
oui voila je sais pas si on l'a bien vu
à la caméra imagine